como se llegó a un tal distanciamiento
la presencia francesa esta hora señalada
por una parte del pueblo maliense que
toma buena parte de la retórica de las
autoridades
no podemos ser subyugados no podemos
convertir el país en una esclavitud se
acabó no hay zona de influencia en todo
caso mal y no forma parte de la zona de
influencia de ningún país de díaz del
pib la junta en el poder en bamako
denuncia lo que considera como una
política imperialista de francia y
rechaza las acusaciones de ilegitimidad
procedentes de parís pues fue después de
dos golpes de estados sucesivos en menos
de un año que las reacciones entre ambos
países se deterioraron el primero en
agosto de 2020 con el derrocamiento del
presidente y brain bubacar keita el
segundo en mayo de 2021 con la retoma
del poder por parte de los militares y
el fin del gobierno civil de transición
que está junto que quiere permanecer en
el poder otros cinco años después de
haber permanecido dos años en el poder
tras dos golpes de estados sucesivos
como vienen a dar lecciones sobre la
constitución estas declaraciones se
hicieron el día después de que malí
anunciara la expulsión del embajador
francés en bamako esto supuso la
culminación del deterioro de las
relaciones franco malienses
especialmente en torno a la cuestión de
la presencia militar francesa emmanuelle
macro había anunciado una retirada
gradual el pasado mes de junio la
presencia de mercenarios rusos del grupo
wagner que vinieron a sustituir a los
soldados franceses en la lucha contra
los grupos yihadistas
aceleró el repliegue